so we're gonna give an example of how
easy it is to use the identity aware
proxy to take a typical corporate
enterprise app and make it available to
your users now the specific app we're
going to use in this case is as
enterprise as it comes
it's Oracle e-business suite running on
Google cloud platform and as a company
we want our users to access this
application whether they're in the
office or they're out on the road so
let's see how simple that is to do with
IIP Neal's gonna click the button to
turn on IP he's then gonna tell us what
domain he wants to publish that
application for and now users in that
domain and only that domain can access
the application so let's test it out
he's gonna flip over to a browser tab
now first thing is there's no VPN
software installed on this machine we
are just navigating to the URL now first
he's gonna try his personal gmail
account which has not been authorized
for this application and sure enough
he's denied now he's gonna try it with
his corporate account which has been
authorized and he gets the username he
gets the password but now he will get
prompted to enter his second key
authentication so if you look on the
sides I think we're gonna project that
up in a second
well okay trust me he pushed there it is
he pushed the security key I think you
know what that works like and now he's
taken directly into the application
without having to have another
additional login step needed not only is
this easier for the developer it's
easier for the admin and Lord knows it's
easier for the end-user rather than
hassling with a bunch of VPN software
and it's more secure because we're not
trusting anybody who just happens to
come in through a VPN tunnel
so that's IEP